Going into Avengers: Endgame, fans were prepared
for everything; the surviving squad pulling
off an epic mission, fallen heroes getting
un-dusted and returning to the world of the
living, Thanos tasting his just desserts,
and much more.
They were also bracing themselves for the
possibility that some who were spared in Thanos'
universe-decimating Snap in Avengers: Infinity
War would sadly not make it to the end this
time around.
If you haven't figured it out by now, there
are major Avengers: Endgame spoilers incoming.
Still here?
Let's continue.
Endgame featured fewer deaths than anyone
had anticipated.
Of the deaths in the movie, one was heroic
and heart-wrenching, another wasn't so much
a passing away as it was a passing on, and
one was completely unexpected.
It's that last one that we need to talk about.
It's time to address what happened to Black
Widow in Avengers: Endgame.
In the first act of the film, Black Widow
serves as a strong leader who keeps the surviving
Avengers in contact with one another five
years after the Decimation.
She organizes meetings at Avengers HQ, checking
in with the other heroes around the galaxy
to receive status updates on how the Earth
and other worlds are faring.
Black Widow also makes it her personal mission
to track down her fellow original Avenger
Clint Barton, who abandoned his Hawkeye identity
and assumed his ruthless Ronin persona after
the snap took his wife and children.
All this felt like Endgame was showing viewers
that Black Widow could rise to the occasion
to marshal the Avengers and company after
they complete their Time Heist.
If one or all of her teammates bit the dust,
Black Widow could step up to continue leading
the Avengers.
She has the skill and the personality, and
she's been acting as a de-facto supervisor
of the team for five whole years.
That's not how things pan out.
Black Widow never gets the chance to continue
leading the way.
She doesn't even get to finish the heroes'
mission to travel back to the present day,
because Black Widow is the first hero to die
in Avengers: Endgame.
Her death comes when she and Hawkeye head
back a few years into the past and touch down
on Vormir, the remote planet where the Soul
Stone is located.
As everyone knows, in order to acquire the
Soul Stone, one must make an equal exchange:
"A soul for a soul."
Thanos tossed his adoptive daughter Gamora
off the cliff on Vormir to call the Soul Stone
his own, and Black Widow and Hawkeye must
do something similar in Endgame.
It's either her or him, they can't both survive
and get the Soul Stone.
Black Widow makes the bold decision to sacrifice
herself and allow Hawkeye to retrieve the
Soul Stone, help the Avengers bring the dusted
back to life, and reunite with his family.
And we know she dies: the film shows Black
Widow laying motionless on the ground, blood
pooling around her head.
Longtime MCU fans are understandably pretty
upset and confused about it.
While the movie made it seem like there's
little chance Black Widow can be revived,
this isn't actually the end for the hero in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Marvel Studios is working on a Black Widow
solo movie, directed by Australian filmmaker
Cate Shortland, and is likely aiming to release
it in theaters sometime in the next few years.
Details about the film's plot are sparse right
now, but it's reportedly planned to be a prequel
set just after 2010's Iron Man 2 and before
the events of 2012's Avengers.
Meanwhile, other reports claim that Black
Widow partially takes place in the time when
Natasha served as an agent for the Soviet
Union's KGB organization, and then skips ahead
to 15 years after the fall of the KGB in the
1980s.
Marvel has yet to confirm any story specifics,
though a prequel-slash-origin-story set-up
sounds pretty plausible.
That would allow for an easy explanation as
to why Black Widow is back on the big screen.
The studio could also use the same digital
de-aging technology it did with Samuel L.
Jackson for his role as Nick Fury in Captain
Marvel, which is set in 1995, to make Johansson
look younger for a Black Widow origin story.
Meanwhile, Avengers: Endgame isn't the true
end of Phase 3 of the MCU, there's still time
for the franchise to hint at what's next for
Black Widow.
She has connections to S.H.I.E.L.D. and to
Nick Fury, having joined the team after working
for the KGB, and we know Fury and Agent Maria
Hill will appear in the real Phase 3-closer:
Spider-Man: Far From Home.
It's possible the upcoming film could weave
in mentions of Black Widow's past, or feature
a post-credits scene set a few decades in
the past that teases the Black Widow solo
movie.
After all, a Black Widow is a kind of spider.
Then again… maybe not.
It's all a mystery for now, but fans should
find comfort in knowing that they haven't
seen the last of Black Widow, even after her
devastating death in Endgame.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.